ces soldats nous montrent comment ils
opèrent d'ordinaire
le démineur avance son premier
centimètre après centimètre
il y a beaucoup de mines en plastique
qui n'ont presque pas de partie
métalliques
donc on ne peut pas utiliser de
détecteurs à métaux
notre groupe se fait souvent tirer
dessus
au missile grades au mortier à
l'artillerie
mais que faire d'autre
suite de la démonstration la mine est
détruite à une distance de sécurité
[Musique]
dans ce camp à une vingtaine de
kilomètres de la ligne de front la
brigade s'entraîne entre deux combats
[Applaudissements]
au Alexandre vient ici une fois par
semaine pour les cours de déminage
lui-même s'est formé en Pologne l'an
dernier
je me suis entièrement consacré à
prendre cela j'ai appris plein de choses
et ça m'a plu
Alexandre voudrait qu'ils aient plus de
drones pour localiser les mines en
plastique
il nous faut des drones à caméra
thermique pour nous les démineurs parce
que les mines chauffent et quand il y a
du soleil le drone les voit très bien
jusqu'à présent malgré des terrains
extrêmement miner ces unités ont réussi
à avancer mais les choses se compliquent
la première ligne de défense russe la
plus proche de nous nous avons fait
notre maximum pour les empêcher dominer
et malgré cela ils ont posé 8 lignes de
mines antichard mais au-delà les champs
de mines sont plus grands beaucoup plus
grands
une épreuve inouïe pour ces hommes qui
combattent depuis plus d'un an sans
relève
mais ces soldats disent malgré tout
vouloir continuer jusqu'à la victoire